two uninhabited Pacific Islands more than 5,000 miles from the UK one will be inhabited by 14
British men while a separate island will be home to 14 British women for six weeks they
will be utterly alone with only the clothes they stand up in and a handful of basic tools
filming everything themselves when pushed to the limits of human endurance will it be brute power
for your boys or mental strength the Windsor day oh my god oh my god who will have what it
takes to stay alive tonight we follow the men's island
you're on
like actually could have died survival will be harder than ever they'll have to endure the height
and harsh tropical storm season everyone's aware everyone's cold everyone's miserable everyone's
tired they'll have to find their own water and hunt for their own food what the effing hell is
that have these modern-day men got what it takes to survive and survive and survive and survive and
survive and survive and survive and survive and survive and survive and survive and survive
and survive and survive and survive and survive and survive you are three and a half hour making
you are three and a half hour making
you are three and a half hour making soap could be done in 25 minutes you tell
soap could be done in 25 minutes you tell
soap could be done in 25 minutes you tell any Chef that cooking for 11 people is
any Chef that cooking for 11 people is
any Chef that cooking for 11 people is physically easy and your stabbing
three weeks ago fourteen British men
three weeks ago fourteen British men were cast away on this remote Pacific
were cast away on this remote Pacific
were cast away on this remote Pacific Island
Pacific Island
Living on the edge of existence...
OK, Vic, go now, go now. Right, that's it.
..until 47-year-old Vic...
Here we go, puppy dogs!
..led them to capture and kill...
Bullshit!
..the island's number-one predator.
We've just caught a prehistoric animal!
But despite their best efforts,
they've not been able to repeat the success.
Truck empty.
The onset of starvation looks upon us.
And feast has turned to famine.
Hey, look, you can see Piers's heart beating through his chest.
Boys, there's no meat on you.
I think we're going to run into some really hard times
in the next couple of weeks, and we'll see.
It'll test everybody's mettle, mine as much as anybody else.
Guys, there's a snake here.
Keep track of it, we're coming.
OK, Bonnie.
Knock it off.
Oh, my gosh.
Bonnie, you've become a killer.
It's food, but I take no pleasure from doing that whatsoever.
It's the second bloody animal I've ever headed since being here.
Killer.
In the four days since the men caught and ate the crocodile,
they've had to survive on slim pickings.
Oh, hello.
It's eaten... It's a little bird or something.
..a baby bird!
Look at that.
Oh!
A bird and a snake.
Get him on the fire too.
Yeah, man.
He's been there.
It's like snake crisps.
It's very, like, pork-scratching.
Oh, man, guilt.
Apart from the odd, opportunistic kill,
the only man who's been able to provide anything
like a regular supply of food for the group is 47-year-old Vic.
Woo!
Hoo!
Look at the size of that bitch!
Woo!
If I didn't have another mouse to feed, I would live like a king.
There's no two ways about that.
It's a shame nobody else is raking food in,
cos that would be helpful.
If he wants to go out and catch amazing fish
and keeps me fed every night, I'm not going to stop the guy.
But even with Vic's contributions,
the men are burning far more calories than they're consuming.
I'm slowly evaporating.
Soon to disappear down the plughole.
What happens in these periods of starvation
is that the body starts to eat into its own fat reserves
and key muscle groups, like your legs,
that you desperately need in a survival situation.
And then, over time, as the brain also gets starved of nutrients,
that decline becomes mental as well as physical,
and that then affects your ability to make smart,
rational decisions.
Yeah, that's new, that's fresh.
This is dry as a bone, this stuff.
We got it? Got it.
Got it.
Every day, the men face a round of essential back-breaking chores.
I feel pretty tired.
Which leave them little time or energy for hunting.
With no food to sustain them,
the group's cook, Sam Brown,
is doing his best to feed the fish.
He's doing his best to rustle up an edible lunch
from leftover fish bits, crocodile bones and limpets.
Put the stew on, we're boiling the bones down,
we're going to save the big bones so we can make a stock.
I'm trying to feed 11 people in the next hour or two hours.
A lot of the cooking has fallen on my shoulders.
I'd rather do it and do it well
than watch someone else it up and go hungry
or I have to pick fish scales out of my food.
Oh, for f***'s sake, guys.
What?
F***ing filled with limpet guts.
We've got 11 bowls, three of which have been used as spittoons.
That's overnight rotting limpet guts.
That's disgusting and that's going to give us diarrhea,
vomiting, that's going to get you off the island really fast.
Somebody needs to be on washing up detail.
We'll wash all them? Yeah.
They don't wash themselves, boys.
I think what you just said, they're a little bit unfair there, Sam.
I'll talk to them when we get back. No, no, why didn't you do it?
Do what? Why didn't you take them down and wash them?
Cos I'm washing the fire and I'm cooking the soup.
That's not a massive, hard task, though, is it?
Well, if that soup pot falls over... We're all staffed.
We're all f***ed. It's not a physically hard task, though, is it?
That's all I'm going at. It's not a physically hard task.
Some of us are really working really hard.
We're all sweating our balls off.
We are. OK, mate, cook a pot of soup and we'll talk.
That's all I'm saying.
There are one or two people that are fantastic at
avoiding what they're meant to do
and looking busy doing very little.
I kind of think, like, if a tree falls in the forest
and Vic's not there to hear it, it doesn't count.
Like, only work that he does
or work that people do right next to him counts.
F*** that shit.
The men on the island, they're spending every waking hour
in each other's company,
and they get no respite from the intensity of that soup.
And in many ways, it's little surprise
that they're starting to turn on each other.
OK.
This should be good.
After a morning of hard labour,
the hungry men sit down, hoping to enjoy Sam's soup.
God, it smells funky, doesn't it?
Smells like crap.
There is some distinct smell of poo about this.
Smells a bit like dog shit, doesn't it? Yeah.
I just couldn't swallow it.
I literally couldn't swallow it.
It almost made me puke.
After a barely edible lunch,
Vic is determined to have a decent dinner.
I might fish.
What choice do I have?
I don't want to eat limpets again, they're crap.
I'll eat them, but they're crap.
Flagging after their morning chores,
the rest of the men decide to stay behind and camp.
Everything's an effort.
That's how I feel right now.
Knackered, boys.
Absolutely knackered.
Completely knackered.
Nobody asks me to go fishing,
but they know I'll go fishing to get food.
And I know they're doing the daily chores,
but guys just aren't going that extra yard.
Come on, boys.
Once you've finished your duties or you don't have much of a duty,
that ain't end of the day, is it?
I am prejudiced against everybody that isn't me,
because if you all did it my way, it'd be a much better place.
But I provide for my family.
I'm a good father.
I'm a good husband.
I'm a good husband, I hope.
I hope I'm an excellent lover.
I don't know.
I'm going to cope without speaking to my wife and kids
for that length of time.
I've no idea.
I really don't know.
No idea.
Gives me goosebumps.
Not sure.
Dude, you are an absolute fish-tickling bastard, aren't you?
Late afternoon.
Do you want a hamburger?
After four hours of fishing,
Vic has single-handedly provided dinner for the rest of the men.
That is so hard.
I'm fucked.
Nobody been and got any coconut, no?
No.
It's getting harder and harder every day,
coming back and seeing everybody laid on fucking beach
and I'm catching fish.
No, I'm all right.
I don't need to sit down.
I need coconut.
I need water.
Coconuts we're getting tomorrow.
Fucking hell.
I thought we were going out for coconut or something.
How difficult would it be for two or three lads to go across
and get a bag full of coconuts?
Do you want me to do that as well?
Fed up of the group taking him for granted,
Vic's made a big decision.
Bollocks to it.
I'm not fishing any more.
Somebody else go fishing.
I might have a couple of days off.
See how everybody fares then.
If somebody else has turned to step up to the plate.
Wowzers.
You've done incredibly well, Vic.
Yeah, you really have, mate.
You've done it absolutely brilliantly.
You absolutely nailed it.
Thanks so much.
I have a couple of things to say,
and I'm unsure whether to say them now,
cos I don't want to spoil the atmosphere,
or save them till the end of the night.
So, do I do them now?
Say them now.
Say them now?
Let's have them now.
OK.
Today, I spent fishing all day on my own.
But we're all sat round here,
happy as pigs in shit, eating, though, now,
and I went without a buddy.
Perhaps you shouldn't have gone without a buddy.
But if I hadn't have gone when I went,
we wouldn't all be eating.
I certainly don't want to be busting a gut
and come back to see people kipping, pampering,
tossing it off, doing whatever.
It's not fair. It's not fair.
That's top and bottom of it.
It's not fair.
It's a very good point, Vic.
It is.
And I'm glad you've raised it.
So, I'll put my rods down,
you'll fish for your own snap,
and I'll eat limpets like restiers.
The group's most skilled hunter
has gone on fishing strike.
That's it?
Fish out.
OK?
Yeah, that's fair.
Understood.
The burden of finding food
will now fall on the rest of the men.
We are knackered.
We are screwed.
We have relied solely on fish,
rod catching,
most of them from Vic.
But tomorrow, I'm a bit worried,
cos I'm not sure the guys are going to cope.
It scares me.
I think everyone's feeling a little bit sluggish today,
aren't they?
Yeah, I know what you mean.
7am.
Dan and Sam Brown are on the early morning water run.
How are you feeling after your little debate yesterday?
Oh, with Vic?
Yeah.
Pretty good?
I think Vic was just maybe
trying to pick a bit of a fight yesterday.
Yeah.
He likes to push buttons.
I think he likes to niggle.
He likes a little...
Yeah.
You know, he sort of...
He has this sort of, like,
oh, I'm nice as pie, da-da-da.
Fuck off, he is.
Where's my hat?
Last night, 47-year-old Vic,
the group's most successful hunter,
announced that he was going on fishing strike.
I'm absolutely knackered.
Are you?
Yeah, yeah, I am, yeah.
Just trudging out, catching fish and trudging back
day after day after day after day after day.
It's not fair.
How many fishing lines have you hooked up before, Phil?
None.
The burden of finding a fish supper
now lies with the other men.
There is absolutely no food in this camp.
There is no reserve.
There's no larder that we have here at the moment.
So if we don't catch anything today, we don't eat.
Right, so where are the points to go fishing?
Although refusing to fish himself,
Vic doesn't want to go hungry,
so he offers the men some advice.
Get your fish.
So he offers the men some advice.
Get your hook and push it through the limb pit at the top.
OK.
Then turn the limb pit and come back through the soft gel.
Feel, feel, feel.
Boom.
But if hidden on it, I would say just hidden
and right on the edge.
Yeah.
Cos they nibble on the edge
and they want them to just nibble it and get caught.
You undermine me every time when I start telling about stuff
and it's rude.
Please don't do it.
Sorry, Vic.
OK?
I thought I was adding to you.
No.
So if you put two limb pits on...
He was very quick to swipe at me
and I think maybe Vic has lost perspective a little bit.
He thinks that he's the kingpin
and that he is providing more than anyone else
and doing more than everyone else.
I don't know if he feels he needs to contribute,
so if we all think he's contributed or...
I don't know, but it's rude.
He shouldn't do it.
I'm thinking three, maybe four bottles around each pole
and then just like that all the way along.
We are going to adapt and overcome.
36-year-old Will has come up with an ambitious plan
to fish the deeper waters surrounding the island.
We've got to make a raft
so we can get in the middle of the channel,
massive hook, big fish bait.
I would love to have a tuna.
That would be the best day ever.
Imagine that.
Sashimi.
We don't have any oil drums or anything.
What we've got on this island
is shedloads of empty plastic bottles.
Fingers crossed she'll float.
Right.
Let's get cracking.
While he waits for the men to find him food,
Vic takes the opportunity
to make a bed for himself.
So unlike the others,
he'll be protected from critters on the jungle floor.
Look at that natural twine.
What an absolute biscuit.
Yeah, I'm happy with this so far.
I don't have a double bed, I'm afraid,
so I can't interest my wife in sleeping with me this evening.
So I'm just going to single it up.
Having isolated himself from the other men,
Vic's thoughts are increasingly turning to family.
I had a very unnerving dream last night about home,
which was very horrible.
It woke me up in not such a pleasant mood.
I'm missing home desperately.
I keep thinking more and more about my wife and kids every day.
I could do with a kiss and a cuddle off my missus,
squeeze the life out of a blesser.
It's time to get to work.
I'm
ready to go.
Will's raft is ready to set sail.
I came up with the idea,
I shall name this raft
after my two gorgeous daughters, Freya and Pippa.
Shall we call it Fripster?
Nice, mate.
I'll get it, guys.
It looks like a bunch of bottles attached to some flanks,
because it is a bunch of bottles attached to some flanks.
But our livelihood and our dependency on food relies on it.
So go on, Fripster.
Fingers crossed we're in orbit launch.
Get some fish.
I name this boat Fripster the First.
Long may she catch us fish from the deep.
Right, on we get.
Are you ready?
You're sailing the Fripster Road.
Come on, lads.
See you in two weeks.
Bye.
She floats!
I think one of the real unsung heroes in the survivor's arsenal
is resourcefulness, being able to look at an everyday object
and think of clever, ingenious ways of using it to help you.
The risks are big,
but the spoils could be even bigger if that raft succeeds.
Bigger strokes, mate.
Reach.
After a huge joint effort from all the men,
apart from Vic, the raft appears to be a success.
Most of the group are now out trying to catch supper.
I've not got the patience for fishing, I tell you that for nothing.
Leaving the gruelling job of firewood to Vic, an IT consultant,
Kyle.
Kyle, why do we need a shitload more kindling today than we have done?
It's not heavy stuff, is it?
Yeah.
Kyle's still quite gifted at doing very little.
But that's the problem with intelligent people,
because they think they're cleverer than the people
that they're out doing the job for.
They think they can out-think them.
When it comes to manual labour, Jesus Christ, lads,
stop getting all crazy.
It's manual labour, which is every job we've got.
I think on this island there will be people that come off,
physically bollocks, regardless of diet, whether we eat or we don't eat,
and there'll be guys come off who aren't.
And if we're not all hanging out of our arse at the end of this,
somebody hasn't been working hard enough, have they?
Would you agree with that?
No, it could happen where we're not all spent.
We work hard as a team, we achieve a lot,
and at the end, we're not all sort of hanging out of our arses.
That could happen. What the fuck are you talking about?
I'm talking English. I'm just talking English.
I'm uneducated, you have to lower it down to my level.
What, didn't you understand? The term we use in Yorkshire,
layman's terms, every job is a manual job.
Do we agree? Yeah. Yeah.
So, if we all plough into that 100% manually,
we will all be bollocksed at the end of this journey.
I've already said I don't think at the end of this...
Right, then, let me just say it again, then.
All it goes on about is this is a physical place,
every task in here is physical.
Whoop-de-doo. You know, that's brilliant,
but we're not all just grunts that have been sent out here
to bash on bits of wood.
You can talk your way around whatever you want,
top and bottom of it is, it's a physical island,
every job is physical, we should all be bollocksed.
If not, somebody's carrying somebody else.
That's the top and bottom of it.
Mid-afternoon.
Still reeling from yesterday's argument
with Vic, Sam Brown is trying to catch some dinner.
Vic keeps making little remarks to me that just make me seethe.
So, what was getting his goat this morning?
Oh, mate, a whole load of things.
If we can catch some fish...
Hopefully, Vic will be in a slightly better mood.
After three hours on the water,
Barney and Sam haven't had a single bite.
So, what are you thinking with this rod?
I'm thinking, I don't know,
maybe they always...
They always say, patience is a virtue, don't they?
And I'm quite impatient.
Is that line tight?
No.
No, no bite.
Oh, fuck it, let's go in.
With nightfall approaching, the other men also return to camp.
Vic is waiting to see how many fish they have caught
in his absence.
No joy, fella?
No, I had a nice day fishing, as you'd say, Vic.
Not catching.
Old dogs should learn new tricks.
Listen when I tell him.
Did you not listen?
No.
Four hours fishing and one poxy trigger.
I fucking hate fishing.
It's exhausting just standing there in the sun
for X amount of hours.
Charlie caught a fish.
Well, that ain't feeding nobody, is it?
That ain't feeding Jack shit.
It's just limpets again.
The men's attempts to provide dinner without Vic's help
have been a miserable failure.
Desperation corner over here.
Mm-hm.
The pressure is on me to feed everybody.
It's almost as though I am expected to grab a rod
and go out and catch fish so everybody else can eat.
And that ain't good. I don't like that.
See you in the morning, ladies.
With no food in camp, Vic opts for an early night in his new bed.
You on the beach, sir?
Oh, dear.
Oh, yeah.
Let me get myself ready for bed.
Oh, dear.
Oh, dear, God, yeah, that's lovely.
That is...
He has to remember that we are a team here
and with certain things, he is quite selfish.
Does not get any better, does it?
For a family man, I might have expected him to be
more considerate of others.
Oh!
Oh, boys, you don't know what you're missing!
MUSIC PLAYS
MUSIC FADES
Victor's bed is a success.
While on fishing strike, 47-year-old Vic has built himself a raised bed.
MUSIC FADES
Mm, yeah, that was a good night's sleep.
I had some lovely dreams.
For some reason, one of us knew Jonathan Ross
and we ended up in his house,
trying to catch his fish out of his fish tank.
Can't think why.
Oh!
Oh, I love my bed.
Protected from the jungle critters,
Vic has had his best sleep yet.
WHISTLE BLOWS
While the others have had their worst.
Oh, my legs are a bit into shit, my arms are a bit into shit.
Sleeping rough on the jungle floor,
the men have been attacked overnight by a swarm of sandflies.
They're everywhere, covered in them.
They must have, you know, 500 bites or so.
I'm just not having a good reaction to them.
And they're starting to swell up.
You may think on a desert island,
your real enemies are the crocs, the scorpions, the snakes,
but actually it's often the little things you can't see.
And worse of these are sandflies.
They're super itchy, ten times worse than a mosquito.
You scratch away, it's hot, it's humid,
and that's when the bites can become infected.
They have had a monster.
It's a massive gore.
Oh!
This island either wants to decompose you from the outside in
or eat you alive.
Good job I'm not going on a date any time soon.
Reeling from last night's infestation,
the men call an emergency meeting.
I've got to put my hands up and say my insulated bones are so bad,
I can barely walk.
I can't even walk, I can't even go in the sun.
So I'm happy to chop wood and stuff in here,
but if I go in the sun, my legs just flare up
and I can't even move them.
Tomorrow I might be down, but today is absolutely excruciating.
It's like someone's puffing fire into my calves when I move them.
My worry with these bites,
cos they just seem to be, like, escalating a notch,
like, that's...
I worry that, what with all the rain,
some other kind of bug might come up,
a bug might have hatched and might be starting to feast on us.
Today, priorities.
I think we just concentrate on just trying to get
as many of these beds up as possible.
Raised beds are the group's best protection against further attacks.
Right, are you ready? Cos this one might jump.
Having built his own yesterday,
Vic temporarily ends his work to rule to lend a helping hand.
I think all of us, there's a full team of 11,
get stuck into beds, everybody's bed.
Come on, give it some.
Come on, it ticked!
I might be quite pushy with it, so we really get stuck into it.
Scamp on it, fella.
All 11 stone here.
Bingo!
Whoo! That's what a bit of graft does for you, boys!
Whoo!
Right, my furor, what do you think?
Perfect.
With all available hands,
with hands on beds and nobody hunting or fishing,
cameraman Sam Brown has once again spent the morning
trying to conjure up something for lunch.
I feel a little bit like this child catcher this morning.
We're going to boil them all to death and then eat them with soup.
Shush, my pretties, it's nearly over.
I think the only job I haven't done so far on this tour
is the difficult task of cooking.
Mmm, cooking.
Right, Sam, there's guys up there busting their knackers.
I don't know how many blisters.
I'm going to help the lads with wood, that's all.
I've just been up to help the lads with wood
and there's no more for me to carry down.
Let's chop some down, then.
If he keeps going like that, you know, I'll react.
You know, I know I will.
It's good for us to vent. Fucking hell.
Shit!
It's good to get it off your chest now and again, Barney.
You lazy bunch of bone-idle bastards!
Makes us all feel much better.
They're chopping wood, they're not busting your guts.
I can't help them chop more because I don't have a fucking machete.
He's only got three and a half.
A leaderless group fighting to stay alive
is always going to face conflict.
And what happens is individuals tend to push their own agendas
and that, in turn, takes away valuable time and valuable energy
for the things that really matter.
How's the soup looking, Sam?
Really good, mate. Really, really good.
Your three-and-a-half-hour making soup could be done in 25 minutes.
You want to...? Really?
How difficult can stirring soup be?
To some, it would look like you didn't want to go do the harder job.
Excuse me?
Some would say it's because you didn't want to go bust a gut.
I would say, fuck you to that person. That's what I'd say.
Hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on.
Shall we just calm it down a bit?
We're here for another, what, three or four weeks?
Just let's fucking calm down, eh?
There's no need to be like this.
So you're saying I'm avoiding graft, Vic? Is that what you're saying?
Are you?
That sounded very much like you were just a second ago.
You're answering the question with the question, are you?
What? Are you?
What? Am I avoiding graft? Yeah.
I fucking don't think so, man.
Then why are you biting, then? What?
Cos you've been niggling for weeks.
Have I?
This is what it boils down to for me, Vic.
You act like certain jobs are like macho jobs,
fishing, chopping wood, everything else,
women's work.
That's the feeling I get, right?
And if that's cooking, that's fucking carrying water,
whatever it is, in your head, it's like,
this is graft, this is good, everything else, not difficult.
I think feeding everybody is one of the most important jobs on this island.
So do I.
Every job is a manual job.
Some jobs, boom, they're done. 25 minutes, they're done.
And every three quarts of an hour, you steer it.
Is that right?
What I'm trying to do, Vic, is get as many good meals out of this as I can, right?
Rather than just use it once and throw it away.
You don't need it.
Yeah.
So maybe just keep your comments to yourself if you don't know about it, huh?
I thought we were allowed to hear his comments.
Yeah, well, it's great, but if you want to fucking, like,
if you want to piss me off, you're going about it the right way.
Some jobs are physically easy, some jobs aren't.
Is that a better way to put it?
You tell any chef that cooking for 11 people is physically easy
and he'll stab you in the fucking eye.
We have a warning for you, mate.
Oh, baby!
We look absolutely furious.
If a mate said that to me, I'd fucking hit them, you know?
If someone at work said that, we'd have trouble, you know?
Fucking butt. I'd just... I'd take...
There's no good way to take that, right?
I take that as, like, a stab at my integrity.
Fuck it, man.
I look forward to sitting down in some 25-minute soup at some stage.
We have built the honeymoon suite.
It is strong enough for the rampy-pampy, you'll see, yeah.
4pm.
After a day of hard graft, the beds are finished.
Welcome to the chateau.
Let's open the curtain.
And that there is the most uncomfortable beds
anyone will ever sleep on.
Oh!
This is where the magic happens.
It's not too bad, actually.
I will say one thing. What?
Right above your head, a lot of daylight.
That, Piers, is my skylight.
The men will now have better protection from the jungle critters.
But the day of hard physical labour has left them hungry and shattered.
I am running on empty.
I feel like I'm lugging my body about.
I can't even stand up straight.
I'm starting to sweat.
I'm starting to sway, so I can just slurp my words a bit.
Since Vic went on fishing strike,
the men have survived on Sam's leftover soup and slithers of coconut.
And Vic isn't impressed.
If I eat any more of this shit, I'm going to puke.
It's horrible.
Coconut.
Yay!
That's your shit sort of iron needle.
Mother Nature, you can be a cruel, cruel mistress.
Do you know that?
She's not going to beat me.
There's nothing going to beat me.
Fucking hellfire.
Disgusting.
Ah, screw it. That's it. I've had enough.
Come on, Victor, let's have some fish.
Despite Vic's strike, he's determined to catch a decent fish supper
and persuades Kyle to join him on the raft.
Instead of catching little fish, I want to be catching some that are bigger.
What's getting out of you?
With my health and safety hat on, I'd be more worried that we've got a homemade raft
in some very strong currents in a very deep piece of water.
Vic and Kyle are already 200 yards from shore.
Should something happen, they're dangerously out of their depth.
Oh, this is something, Vic.
Ooh.
Has Daddy got a tug?
Oh!
Do you have a tug?
I think Daddy might have a tug, pal.
Get on the end of that, kid.
Feel the end of that.
I'm not sure what it is.
What the fuck is that?
I don't know.
What's that?
What the effing hell is that?
We've got ourselves a fucking eel, kid!
You, sir, are going fucking nowhere.
Can you hold that for me?
Yeah, of course.
Thank you.
Right, now I've pinned him.
Pinned him down to the side.
Good man.
I now need to club him with something, and I think that might be this.
Have I got plenty of space?
Oh, yes.
Yeah, I do believe that's him.
As we speak now.
Right, don't panic, don't panic, don't panic, don't panic.
Oh, you fucker, yeah.
I don't like this fucking fighting bat bollocks at all.
I really don't.
They're 200, 300, 400 yards out now.
And still going.
One of the most precious resources that the men actually have
is their own energy.
Yeah.
They're living hand-to-mouth, struggling for every mouthful of food.
The temptation is to go to greater and greater lengths
to get that precious energy.
Right, that's it.
I can now tie you up.
Safely.
But here's the danger.
The more malnourished the men get,
the more their judgement gets impaired.
That's when the small mistakes become full-blown emergencies,
and that can happen in the blink of an eye.
Two of those, pretty nice bat.
Come on.
That's one hell of a tide, isn't it?
They're getting carried.
We are going backwards.
Right, go on, paddle, paddle, paddle. Don't stop.
Vic and Kyle are attempting to paddle back to the beach.
I don't like this, mate.
No, neither do I.
Start paddling now!
But they've been caught by a powerful undercurrent.
Paddle.
Paddle, guys!
Come on!
You all right?
I think the current's got them.
Come on!
Come on, let's go.
Fucking hell.
Come on!
Come on, boy!
Yeah!
We're going to crash, though!
Come on!
At the mercy of the current,
the raft is on a collision course with the island's treacherous rocky coastline,
which could tear the men to shreds.
Come on, Kyle, dig the fucker in.
Paddle, paddle!
And turn again, you know.
Oh, baby.
It'll... Right, paddle, paddle!
Paddle!
Don't stop, don't stop.
No!
Everybody safe? Everybody OK? No injuries?
Thank the Lord. Thank the Lord for that.
After surviving a near-death experience,
the men are shaken, but physically unscathed.
It all got mangled up and chaffed up.
Their raft, though, is destroyed.
That must have been fucking scary, man.
Yeah, it was.
We were getting smashed on the rocks and everything,
so I do appreciate that.
Sam and Dan's swift actions saved Vic and Kyle from annihilation on the rocks.
It was fucking hairy, mate.
Like, that was... I think that was the closest I've been to coughing on this trip.
Thanks for coming and helping us, guys.
Let's get back to camp before dark.
Yeah, yeah.
First light tomorrow, we'll try and salvage as much of this as we can.
With their raft in tatters and Vic's eel lost to the ocean,
the men now face a second night with empty stomachs.
Where the hell's the rest of the raft?
Oh, shit, is that the raft?
The tripster is no longer, boys.
Yes.
Vic's got a brave face, hasn't he?
But he's really shook up.
He could have just been knocked unconscious,
brain splattered out in a rock.
He could have died.
Like, actually, he could have died.
Vic's near-death experience isn't the only thing on his mind.
It's been a little bit quite difficult today, truth's known, for me.
It's come up to fifth, which is the date of my first date with my missus.
And I'm missing her immensely.
So, tomorrow, I may spend lots and lots of time
contemplating my missus and all that sort of thing.
Morning.
Oh, that was a good sleep.
Oh, morning.
I'm so happy.
Good morning.
After a savage sandfly attack 24 hours ago,
the men have spent their first night
raised off the ground in their own beds.
Good morning.
Oh, last night was wonderful.
Last night was the best unbroken sleep I've had by a mile.
This time, it's Vic who hasn't slept a wink.
Vic looks like he spent the entire night sitting on a fence post.
The poor bugger looks absolutely drained.
He's got a lot of strain today.
Victor looks a little bit edgy today.
I can see him cracking a little bit.
Hopefully, he's all right.
You know, he's not the kind of guy who would show his emotions.
He's definitely that kind of old-school British, macho male.
Today is the 20th anniversary of Vic's first date with his wife.
Never again.
Never in this long.
The greatest thing that ever happened to me,
other than being born, was my wife.
I can't wait to get back to Cheryl.
Smell her, taste her, touch her, feel her.
All them things.
I love that woman so much.
It's immense.
Truly immense.
As human beings, when we're stripped of everything,
the real essence of who we are is laid bare.
Every single one of them
It is just a nature of survival.
It's a nature of enduring hardship.
If you can take a long, hard look at yourself
when you're at your lowest ebb,
and in that moment you can accept what you see,
in my eye, that's what makes you a true survivor.
Devastated. Absolutely devastated.
This is literally what we were getting smashed against yesterday.
It's so dangerous.
Yeah.
Oh, I feel so dreadful at the moment. It's unbelievable.
This beautiful, dangerous paradise can be a killer.
You take your eye off the ball and she's going to bite you in the arse.
The raft crash will stay with me till the day I die.
These guys saved my life.
In camp, Vic calls the men together for a chat.
I'd just like to say if I ever offended anybody, upset them,
unduly, and it weren't deserved, then I apologise.
It won't happen again.
I worry immensely about providing for me and mine,
so perhaps that's why I compensate for working so physically hard,
like a fool, like a donkey.
I've got a fantastic wife and kids,
but I have this overwhelming urge to provide.
It drives me more than anything else,
and the fear of not being able to do that is terrifying.
Terrifying.
Vic, the man that said a few weeks ago,
erm, he does not see the point in crying...
..cried.
The way that you describe your wife and your family
I find inspirational.
I've never known a man to come away with a group of guys
and to say, I love my wife to bits.
She's the best thing I've ever experienced in my life.
I never hear that.
And that's one thing I'm going to take away from you.
I'm going to take that.
Every time you talk about Cheryl, like, I feel like she's in the room.
Don't get me wrong, Vic, you've pissed me off
more than just about anyone here.
But overall, mate, you're worth every ounce of you.
You've lifted us up more times than I can say.
We'd be seriously worse off if you weren't here.
I weren't expecting this. I won't be honest.
Not at all.
I expected difficulties and hungers and confrontation and conflict,
but not to find something out about me.
That was the last thing I expected.
What a great bunch of blokes these really are.
What a great bunch of blokes.
I ain't never going to see eye to eye with them all,
but on this island, it's a family.
It's the island family.
Vic calls an end to his fishing strike
and heads out on his own to catch dinner for the group.
Nice and steady. Nice and fucking steady.
Hold your ground.
We're good. We're good. We're good.
It's been three days since the men had anything substantial to eat
and they are obsessing about food.
There was this documentary about some women
that were still breastfeeding kids at the age of, was it three, four?
I always think that the longer you're on the breast, the better.
What, eight, nine? Yeah.
I think if you're taken off the breast too early...
You become short. ..it stunts your growth.
Well, hello!
Gentlemen. Yes, Vic.
How are we all? What did you get, Vic?
I wish I had a fish for each of us, but alas, I don't.
Oh.
What I can say, though, is this.
Of the five fish I've caught...
Hello! Hello!
..two are the biggest I have ever caught in all my life.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
And one of them is the size of a small dog.
Yeah, boy!
Daddy brought home the bacon.
Yeah! Yeah!
They are massive, Vickers!
For he's a jolly good fellow!
And so say all of us!
He's back to normal Vic fellows.
Woo!
Shouting and whooping and getting fish and stuff like that,
everything that he loves.
Look at the size of that, bitch.
Oh!
Fripster will sail again.
Fripster 2 will sail again.
I can't get the Titanic theme tune in my head.
That was like Titanic.
See, if I was Kate Winslet, who was Leonardo?
LAUGHTER
Oh, it's small.
Sometimes I like to smash him repeatedly in the face,
but I think me and Vic were in danger of becoming quite good friends.
Huge respect for the guy.
Vick! Vick! Vick! Vick! Vick! Vick! Vick! Vick! Vick! Vick!
Woo!
When in doubt, send Vic out!
Yeah!
Next time on The Women's Island...
You are not leaving this island.
I don't care if I have to carry you on my fucking back.
The one thing we need for George is food.
Get the knife! Get the knife!
Come here, come here, come here!
I think it's about time that we get out there and get a bit brutal.
There, there, there, there, there.
Go.
HE GRUNTS
EUGRENIA